on le sait qu il n aime pas p n'a pas
toujours sa langue dans sa poche qu'ils
aient quelque chose à dire à quelqu'un
je vais lui dire après avoir boycotté
une opération marketing des bleus le
joueur s'en prend cette fois au célèbre
site de paris sportifs suite à une
blague pour le moins douteuse sur son
père wilfrid m.ben ap lors du but de son
fils contre l'afrique du sud une blague
qui n'a pas du tout fait sourire le
joueur de 23 ans un peu de respect s'il
vous plaît suite à sa colère le tweet a
été retiré des réseaux sociaux alors
comprenez vous le coup de gueule de qui
la mba p
gilles c'est incroyable cette histoire
c'est de la folie c'est totalement
dégradants ou pas dire que on est non
seulement on exploite son image mais on
fait semblant que ce soit son père c'est
honteux c'est scandaleux qu 2ème map et
merci
d'une très bonne émission lui il défend
ses valeurs qui sont pas celle-là est
cependant si ces valeurs il un beau cul
quand même assez rond tout ce qui s'est
passé et je soutiens totalement killian
mba p non mais c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable mais c'est un vrai moyen que
c'est sidérant que winamax puisque c'est
eux et osé faire ça si son winamax dans
la cause mais la c1 non moi ça me choque
pas c'est un compte parodique c'est ce
qu'on appelle un même on comprend très
bien que c'est pas son père et moi non
mais c'est vrai et j'ai l'impression
qu'il a pris un peu la grosse tête il
n'accepte pas baptisé adam et garde
c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas pris c'est
une star internationale
l'amour de mes coui mais c'est une star
internationale il doit quitter kiel et
aurait aimé qu'on fasse ça que ton père
toit
du monde a souri pendant qu'henri et le
trou pour le sujet
et franchement c'est honteux je suis
papa et moi je moi on fait ça sur mon
père je sais qu'on peut arrêter les mecs
au sérieux qui fabrique franchement mais
en fait il faudra approché du sujet
d'avant sur la grand mère et le
l'application c'est-à-dire qui a
abandonné le problème s'il prône de
l'image c'est ça et jusqu'où on va pour
vendanger savais que j'étais en train de
dire oui en fait ces jours où va est ce
qu'on peut accepter parce que là c'est
pas un type qui déconne comme ça un
twittos qui déconne comme ça c'est
organisé s'est cognée de communication
derrière il ya des mecs qui sont payés
pour réfléchir à ça et ça fait le buzz
ouais c'est la raison ça veut dire
qu'effectivement le seul truc qui
aujourd'hui intéresse la communication
la communication se limite au buzz or on
est sur deux sujets différents quand
même qu'on vende un produit qu'on aime
bape et il a raison a sa raison d'un
faire la gueule et tout parce que c'est
horrible mais de l'autre côté il a fait
le buzz bien sûr n'a pas fait mais c'est
vrai que
tu vois une photo on dit que c'est
tromper c'est impossible c'est
insupportable un peu de respect bien sûr
et très dégradantes pour le plus désolé
mais c'est vrai que marco à rien ils ont
quand même réussi leur coup parce que
tout le monde parle de winamax suis sûr
qu'il ya plein de gens qui connaissaient
le problème de la com contemporaine
c'est à dire qu'en fait il n'y a pas de
bad buzz il n'y a que du buzz et en fait
on a confondu la communication des
entreprises sont confrontées au même
problème c'est un énorme problème c'est
qu'au fond un moment donné qui fixe les
limites et comment il n'y a en de
polémiques en fait que parce qu'il ya ça
a fait réagir du coût et du coup plus tu
réagis bas plus plus on augmente les
vues et plus augmentent les vues plus
ils ont réussi un truc en fait c'est un
cercle infernal mais sérieux c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs moi j'ai vu que m pap et
vous avez parlé d'un google en fait non
c'est pas un coup de gueule ils étaient
très discrets bien sûr très très sobre
jusqu il a dit c'est pas possible un peu
de un peu de respect quoi bien sûr oui
ruby alors moi je trouve ça hyper
irrespectueux vraiment hyper dégradants
c'était moi on parle pas des parents
comme ça en fait clairement on parle pas
des parents comme ça ça se fait pas et
voilà qu'il y en a bavé marasme
enchérissez mons et mon amour je parle
avec lui en dm instagram
voilà on porte un amour de mecs sont pas
des marrants comme ça elle devrait lui
donner du parfum je suis là
d'ailleurs un aspect cyril six mois ses
références de grâce à ses quatre heures
qui a vu de parler la pauvre avec 4
heures je suis bien rennais je les dois
à genève les toits non mais en fait qui
n aiment pas paix est un produit
médiatique donc si on veut le railler ou
faire de la com' positives ou négatives
sur lui c'est le jeu par contre on ne
touche pas aux parents on touche pas à
l'entourage à ces gens qui n'ont rien
demandé qui sont dans l'ombre et qui ont
que le le métal ah non non non non non
il pas dans l'ombre le père de qui anne
la peña maintenant à mes parents on
touche pas on est pas là
il n'est pas dans l'ombre tout le monde
ne savent pas rené par les choix on
n'est pas bon non mais c'était
intéressant c'est la réaction de qui
dirait mbappé en fait là on a un
contraste intéressant entre la polémique
effectivement l'agent principal l'excès
et l'huile à une réaction extrêmement
sobre en fait une infection des troupes
d'une grande aura dignité l'accord en ce
bail était à l'origine et il a des
vraies valeurs puisque en équipe de
france et là il avait refusé de faire
une opération de sponsoring pour
notamment des sites de paris en ligne
pour un soda et pour une entreprise
d'alimentation parce qu'il lutte contre
la malbouffe chez les jeunes et il a
peur des addictions sur les paris en
ligne donc il défend ses valeurs moi je
conservais viable tant que patronne de
public est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qu'on
cherche au niveau people qui a même
aperçu
c'est au moment de la coupe du monde on
avait sorti une couv de lui avec une
jeune femme ça a très bien marché c'est
un vrai people après c'est vrai que il a
énormément de valeur contrairement à
beaucoup d'autres et je l'avais déjà dit
mais c'est vrai que c'est le seul qui
quand ils nous attaquent reverse tous
les tous les tous les honoraires à une
association et il est très très engagé
dans la défense des jeunes non et cetera
donc et si je peux venir il n'a pas du
tout pris la grosse tête non parfois
c'est un amour de mec vraiment un amour
de mai qu'un incroyable